Okay,
just got back from getting my hair cut.
I thought I should probably tell you
this before we start the blog.
Just had two shots of rum with my Greek
barber.
He,
um,
took the shots,
took the shots before the haircut,
so he had those scissors up by my ears.
Coffee on a Tuesday and block 37,
three d movies,
please just stop making them.
So last week the new judge dredd movie
came out and I was excited because it
looked like the old faithful fair of
gratuitous,
slow motion violence and explosions.
And the 1995 one with stallone is bowel
scene.
So I was ready to fandango some ticks
when my friend and general sad news,
Susan Elias told me that it was only
showing in three days,
only three d surely there has to be a
two d showing somewhere.
So I think it's probably a good time to
talk about why I don't like the
troubling new trend of three d movies.
I saw Avatar in three d,
I saw coraline in three d,
but I had to.
I had to cut it off there because for
both of those movies it was like after
45 minutes of finger started pushing
into the center of my forehead.
Maybe this happens to you too,
and if it does,
I can tell you there is a good reason
and it has to do with evolution.
So when we look at something,
anything,
there are a few things that are
happening with our eyes first,
like a camera.
Your eyes are focusing at a certain
distance.
You can imagine.
Focus is sort of like a flat plane
that's moving away from you,
depending on what you're looking at.
Second and unlike a camera,
your eyes are converging on a point,
the object of your gaze.
This convergence is the third point in a
triangle in which the other two points
are your eyes
triangle.
For the hundreds of thousands of years
that humans have been pottering around
and for the many more millions of years
in the history of eyes.
The focus point and the convergence
point have always been the same.
But when you're sitting in a theater
watching a three d movie,
things are a bit different.
The focus point always remains the same.
Always say 60 feet where the screen is,
but the convergence point is always
changing.
Depending on what the director wants you
to see,
the image might be 30 feet away,
it might be 100 feet away.
It's variable.
Now we can do this,
but it takes our brains a few more
milliseconds to adjust to the change.
This is why editing in three d films is
a little bit slower than normal.
As Walter Emerge,
the legendary film editor and sound
designer says,
the CPU of our perceptual brain has to
work extra hard,
which is why after 20 minutes or so
people get headaches,
they're doing something that's 600
million years of evolution,
never prepared them for.
So if you're getting headaches in three
d films,
it's not your fault.
It's Charles Darwin's fault.
No,
no wait.
For years I've been decrying three d
movies,
not because of the serious and seemingly
insurmountable focus convergence issue,
but because I think that they perpetuate
a false equivalency.
I've never seen physical or illusory
immersiveness is the ruler of what makes
an immersive movie.
Some of my favorite d movies are pretty
three dimensional in their own right and
nothing in those ever pops out of the
screen.
And this applies to gratuitous action
movies too.
I mean,
in order to catch him,
he must become him.
Huge scissors cutting by my ears.
And I was like his 30th cut at the day.
So yeah.